can uh you take us back for people who
don't know what was kind of like
your initial look that really kind of
put you on i guess in terms of like how
about this what was your first plaque
and then before that maybe your first
mixtape look my first plaque was
flakovidly
walker flocka
and wild boys with him with machine gun
kelly
shout out to mgk yeah and like two
chainz kernick and [ __ ] like it was like
my first set of plaques that was all
like one year wow yeah
so was was waka kind of the
first guy to kind of
bring you on in terms of just why is big
brother that's his big brother with a
kid he was part of brick squad also i
remember hey shout out to hey
yeah he was and then
waka just kind of
i really made waka first beat that he
really rapped on call we on the way we
rode around for two weeks in the car he
wrote the song for two weeks you know
what i love about waka is people don't
even respect like how amazing of an mc
he is like he could bar somebody out
cause [ __ ] don't even realize
he's from queen's little key you know
what i'm saying like originally yeah for
sure even glaze yeah he's an amazing uh
and like
and then waka just early [ __ ] was so
just ratchet he's just and he really was
doing what he was talking about like
yeah like so that's what made it you
know yeah man that's what made it pop
off